souvent des jeunes gens donc arrivent
chez nous en disant j'ai travaillé avec
papa et je voudrais reprendre
l'entreprise de papa et c'est quand même
plus de 5000 entreprises qui sont dans
cette situation là le chef d'entreprise
donc le dirigeant a plus de 50 ans donc
si on imagine pas maintenant la reprise
d'entreprise il faut c'est maintenant
qu'il faut réfléchir c'est pas quand il
va arriver à 2 ans 3 ans de la retraite
c'est son entreprise c'est c'est sa
passion c'est son cœur qui voudrait don
transmettre donc et transmettre à sa
famille c'est beaucoup plus facile de
transmettre à sa famille à ses enfants
donc là on parle de de transmission à
titre gratuit sinon c'est à titre
onéreux et donc on vend le fond de
commerce on vend le fond anal et là
c'est beaucoup plus déchirant c'est un
accompagnement qui est un peu plus long
d'abord il faut sensibiliser le chef
d'entreprise sur le fait de vouloir
transmettre son entreprise ensuite le
conseil donc nous faisons nous
organisons des réunions d'information
ensuite nous avons la desceil un réseau
de partenaires des notaires des avocats
des experts comptables donc le réseau
avec qui nous avons signé donc un
partenariat à qui nous mobilisons nous
sommes donc des facilitateurs des
conseillers pour drainer donc nos
ressortissants vers ce réseau de
spécialistes qui surtout faites-vous
accompagner faites-vous accompagner par
des par les gens na champ métier bien
sûr mais aussi par le réseau des
spécialistes notamment le réseau des
juristes